[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice dr john
deloney ramsey personality best-selling
author and host of the
extremely popular dr john dolone podcast
is my guest today my my guest my co-host
today
and we're glad to have you here have him
here to answer your questions about your
life
your money your family your money your
boundaries and relationships
and we'll talk with you about what's
going on the phone number is triple
eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five
five two two five jeff
is with us in dallas to start off this
hour hi jeff how are you
i'm doing great how are you doing today
better than i deserve sir what's up
yeah quick question i'm fairly new to
investing i did work with an
elp when i started my new job last
august to select my options
um and when i look at the options now
i'm just curious like i see
like for example in the large cap
options they have i see other options in
the one he told me select i have a
similar rate of return
but the share prices are drastically
different so should i also be
considering their share prices or just
focus strictly on the rate of return
share price means nothing ah okay
it's not got it it has nothing to do
with anything it's just the number of
uh you know people that they have in the
mutual fund divided into that i mean
in your share price times your number of
units equals your total
so i mean you can have a 10 share price
hundred dollar share price it doesn't
affect
uh you know what you're getting and what
you end up with you're going to have the
same
if both of them had an 11.6 rate of
return
uh they're both going to have the exact
same results
got it so in other words if you buy a
share of stock for 100
or you buy a share of stock for 50 and
you put 10 000
in either one and they both go up eleven
point six percent
it's the ten thousand dollars that's
going up not the share
got it okay the total of the ten is
gives you the returns
so you're putting the same amount and
you're buying less units with a higher
share price more units with a lower
share price but
it's really just irrelevant so you're
fine i mean as long as
long as you're in good mutual funds that
are giving you good strong rates of
return
similar to what the stock market's doing
you're going to become wealthy if you
keep following the baby steps
and working your way all the way out
john the good news is that um just like
when you're dealing with a mental health
situation
um uh with a money situation with a
marriage situation with a career
situation with king coleman
these areas of life um
most people don't succeed in an area of
life just because they freaking don't
pay attention it's not because they do
the wrong thing
as much as they just don't do anything
they do nothing right
they just sit there they just go oh well
you know
i wonder what's on tv tonight my
marriage is in the other room burning
down you know
or my kids are in the other room yeah my
kids are in the room doing heroin but i
wonder what's on tv tonight i've got
everybody a screen
a screen everybody's quiet yeah that
means we're winning
right and so and that's what they do
with the money it's just yeah you know
as long as i'm you know
nothing's getting repo'ed so nothing's
burning down so i'm i'm okay
the difference is that guy is paying
attention
at a granular level at a very granular
level
at a nerd level i started to turn and
ask you hey dave
i know we're in front of a couple of 10
million people or so but
what's he talking about but you
explained it so that's good i've
not even gotten that granular level yeah
but i mean if you pull up your mutual
fund statement it says that each
share that you own is that worth x and
you own
y number of shares and x times y is the
amount of money you have
in there so if it's ten dollars and you
know you own a thousand shares then you
have ten thousand dollars
right so um and that's all it is but the
the share is
is a your portion of this mutual
fund that's been mutually funded right
and so if there's
if you're in a mutual fund that's got uh
you know two billion in it
your share is a share of that if it's in
a mutual fund that's got
um you know 500 million in it you know a
fourth of that then your share
is a share of that but the rate of
return is the rate of return return is
the rate of return is the rate of return
it's it's based on the dollars you have
invested total okay not the share price
but
the good news about a guy asking you
know it's easy to make fun go that's
real nerdy who gives a crap you know
because it doesn't talk but the good
news is he's paying attention he's
paying attention and people who are
successful
at any area of their life are the people
that pay attention okay so i've got a
thing i always want to reward people
that pay attention i've got a theory i
want to know what you've been doing for
a lot longer than i have
what why don't people pay attention why
do they pick a thing
that they just choose to tune out on
i don't know my theory is in is my
personal lazy
it's intellectual laziness for me it was
denial it was
okay denial or yeah some kind of a a
repressing
mechanism of some kind yeah i don't want
to face it
my marriage or parenting or my my
physical fitness or my mental
i could go in and be directly involved
in to some degree the route that would
take
right when it comes to finance to the
stock market
it's almost like a presidential election
i can do my right thing
and then you got to step back and let
the thing go right
and there's a there's a fear component
for it for me yeah
yeah i mean buying a house you know you
can't control what house prices are
going to do
they are right but you can go well you
know for the last 75 years
you know here's what they've done i'm
pretty comfortable with that so i'm
gonna buy a house and
probably gonna work out for me you know
you don't have to have this big
you know predictive model of some kind
on your house with your marriage right
like
most people say if i ask this question
there's gonna be the occasional person
that
doesn't like that question but for me
it's always come down to fear but i
don't know what
what it is across the board yeah it can
be it can be laziness yeah
it can be i'm just you know why don't
you want to work out more i'm too lazy
i'm not going to do it once you talk to
your kids
i don't wanna really wanna sw i mean why
did anybody run unless somebody's
chasing them you know
um you know you have that kelly we're
dog getting ready for the
marathon i was running the half marathon
a bunch i was running a few years ago
and she said it's in the bible
what's that that you don't run only the
wicked flea when someone with no one is
chasing
only the wicked flea when no one is
chasing so all of you runners there
kelly's got your back
literally so but you know the
the you so fear it can be fear i'd uh i
can be
i'm overwhelmed i don't know what to do
and so i get paralysis of
the analysis during the headlights or
whatever
it can be it can be laziness yeah um
and uh the problem is in america that
you can
be half but and have a really good life
just coast because everyone's taking it
you're gonna have a really good
life in america being a half butt in
fact the good life is now
in injecting fractals as the nerd way is
creating things that are to be hard for
you
so that you can grow right yeah
i mean you've got to be intentional
about discomfort muscles aren't growing
unless you're sore
that's right you know and lives aren't
growing unless they're unless you bump
your knees my relationships aren't
growing if i'm not having
hard conversations unless i'm going well
man i don't think
yeah yeah but that's leaning into that
there's a success principle to that in
any area
of your life and this intentionality the
power of intentionality
you become what you think about earl
nightingale said
jesus said as a man thinketh in his
heart so is he and when you have
nothing in your brain you're going to
become nothing and there's
plenty of people who are happy to take
your money and just
plop things in your brain for you right
well or
yeah or pat you on the head and tell you
how good you're doing when you really
suck
you know what i'm saying and take your
money doing that exactly oh aren't you
cute
i'll take your subscription fee and
you're not keen
ugly there's nothing cute about that
really
i'm kind of cute yeah well and humble my
mom says i am and humble
well your mom she's obligated
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at backslash
chministries.org
we absolutely believe in it
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
where we talk about your life your money
and your life
the phone number triple eight eight two
five five
two two five patrick is in columbus ohio
hey patrick how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
alrighty so my question is i'm 17 years
old
and i just finished my thousand dollar
emergency fund
which technically covers way more than
six months worth of expenses for me
all i pay is insurance so my question
was should i
keep putting in that to anticipate the
future
for when i move out after high school or
maybe start investing a little bit
or use that to start setting up for your
financial
coach master training who is this guy
wow all right well uh
patrick we teach folks that are in high
school and living with their mom and dad
at home
and foundations for personal finance
that their their
fully funded emergency fund is 500
now then you bring up an interesting
question that someday you're going to
transition and move out as that day
approaches you're going to want to have
a full on uh we'll call it an adult
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses of whatever your life would
look like if you had a job and lived in
an apartment didn't live at home
but that's a different world than you're
living in today in the interim you could
save towards that transition or you
could save towards a different goal i
would not begin investing at this stage
i don't think it's necessary
you got plenty of time you're doing
great you're paying attention
and no i would not suggest you do the
financial coach master training
uh at this stage of the game that's too
expensive an item
uh for you to invest in at your young
age you'll have plenty of time to do
that later
when you want to move into it but i
don't really want to take a 17 year
old's 3 500 bucks away from him and him
not be able to make some money as a
result of doing that because
be highly unusual for someone to come to
a 17 year old for financial coaching
yeah that would be a i have a hard
enough time coming to you man
you've been doing this for a while and
i'm older
yeah exactly so yeah i love talking
about it but it's cool that you know
again
back to what we were saying before the
break uh paying attention oh man
and um you know it's not to say you
can't do any of those things you can
but it's it's uh you know i got my real
estate license three weeks after i
turned 18. i've told this story before
uh and who would buy who should buy you
shouldn't bought a house from me i was
wearing my tom selleck mustache
you know magnum pi i had the uh the
disco
clothes on because i didn't have a suit
and i actually talked people into buying
houses which is not a real good
reflection on them
uh you should not buy your largest asset
from a miniature tom selleck in a disco
outfit
and so um bobblehead made yeah
y'all don't remember magnum pi before he
was doing
um infomercials on
oh anyway yeah
[Laughter]
so there you go but all right sierra is
with us
get me out of the sierras in evansville
indiana what's up sierra
hi dave hi john thank you for taking my
call um
i am new to um your program very good
friend of mine
um gave me your book um total money
makeover i've read that and i've
really tried hard to apply those
principles
long story short i'm a single mom of an
eight-year-old boy
i work two jobs and traditionally i wait
i work six to seven days a week
but my total income projected
um as things stay on track it should be
about 27
to maybe 30 thousand dollars which is
very low
um by total debt which is student loans
picarno and some old uh dead debt by
your standard is about forty thousand
dollars
and i've already paid off eight thousand
within three months
but i just kind of want to know your
opinion do you think it's worth it to
stay
at these jobs because i am sacrificing
so much time for my child
[Music]
you're a warrior princess lady
thank you he is lucky to have you in his
life you're amazing
um well uh
i i think if i'm in your shoes i need to
see
more traction for the sacrifice
right and so i would be willing to give
up some of the hours
if i was being paid a lot more and so
resetting your you know getting some
better jobs that pay more
make it more worth uh in the sense of
the
the advancement that you make on your on
your financial goals
make it more worth the time away now you
don't wanna
i do not wanna sign you up for a thing
where uh he's eight years old and ten
years from today we're still
in the same wheel running and running
and running and running
and you've really made no progress and
he and you pretty much have been gone
the entire time
um he was there that that means your
career path didn't go well
right so uh and uh i'm not concerned
about the old debts
i want to get some of the new one the
current ones that you're paying payments
on out of your life so you got that
money back
each month you don't have to pay it out
to somebody else you can use it for your
family
right so um i think what i would do is
probably work on the career side of
things
uh but no i wouldn't be away from my kid
for minimum wage
as an example okay yeah um that doesn't
that doesn't prove anything except
you're willing to work hard
right um because both of my jobs i'll be
very honest they're they're
very much so dead in jobs i'm a
telemetry technician um
and at a hospital i work um 12 to 16
hours for three days a week and then the
rest of the time i'm waiting tables at a
small restaurant
um our area doesn't really have a whole
lot it's pretty uh
like low income poverty-stricken kind of
area
and i didn't finish my degree so what
did you start your degree in
nursing um but i with kovid i have
decided i don't want to be a nurse i
okay my job i call time of death i deal
with a lot of death and i want to get
away from it
but this is where my insurance is and my
benefits so i'm
honestly i think it's more of i'm scared
to leave because
um you're sure to leave because you
don't have anything better you can't
just cold walk out the door
right of course i would never do that so
what i've got to do is
if i'm in your shoes what i have to do
is i have to have a new goal and say
okay
how old are you by the way i'm 29. okay
so when you're 39 and this kid is 18.
what is sierra doing with her life
that pays double or triple what you're
doing now
right um well my goal i actually have
two goals them
which are polar opposite from each other
um i
love being in the business of
hospitality and um
you know with waiting tables it's really
opened my eyes that i have such a
passion for
being social with people and enjoying
them
that i would love to open my own
restaurant okay
and do that side of things but if we're
talking about like um
another personal business because i've
realized i would like to be my own boss
so i can live the life that i want to
live i
have always had a passion for like
maternity like with babies and
expectant moms so i have considered
opening my own photography business
and just catering to mostly maternity um
birth photos and then newborn photos
which could be you know fairly there's
some interim steps in either one of
those businesses that you could start
immediately
right if you're a good photographer you
can start putting yourself out there as
being willing to take pictures of almost
anything
and work your way towards babies and if
you want to
someday open a restaurant and be in that
business
why don't you start baking something or
starting a small catering business
okay on the side and let that be the
replacement for the waitressing job
as soon as you can get it moving as a
matter of fact you might you might
approach your existing boss about
letting you manage his new catering
outfit
okay and uh then later on maybe he gives
it to
you after you get it running and then
later on you become his competition when
you open your own restaurant
or maybe not because you open a
different kind of restaurant that's
really not a competitor of his but
the bottom line is you could start
cooking out of your kitchen
and doing small catering things by
yourself paying a friend out of your
back pocket
to help you with the trays and begin
your career
because you need to do something to move
in the direction of your desired future
and your kid is going to watch you work
and scratch and claw is going to
participate and help you out yeah our
friend christy wright did that with your
mom's baking shop
a single mom's baking shop and you're
playing a long game with him
and man he's going to step back and tell
the story for generations about his
how his single mom scratched and clawed
and hung out
and dragged him along hang on i'm going
to put you in her business boutique
academy
she just closed it but i can open it i
own it and
um put her in there and give her a
business boutique book and let's get her
going here
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five
two two five annette is with us in
sacramento hi annette how are you
i'm great thank you so my question today
is i'm a teacher and i'm due to retire
in four more school years my husband is
already retired
but we've not had to touch his through
savings plan
or his social security at all i have a
required retirement
that i put into through my school
district
but about seven years ago after
reading starting to realize that you
know what
we want to have more money when we
retire well i didn't realize about
annuities so i
invested into a teacher annuity and then
after reading your book a few years ago
realized that was a mistake and so um
i've stopped putting into the teacher
annuity but there's about 125 000
dollars into that
and we fully funded a roth ira
for last year and for this year are
ready
we're completely debt-free including our
rental property
and our house should be paid off the
goal is that it'll be paid off before i
retire or i'm not retiring because i
don't want to have a house payment
afterwards
so i don't know
what to do with that teacher annuity i
asked our financial advisor
if i should try to roll that into
a roth ira but he said then i would be
taxed
on that full amount and with what i make
that my husband's retirement
were we're like at 130 140 000 a year
and he goes you would be paying a lot in
taxes
yeah but he didn't offer he's right i
agree with him but he didn't offer for
you to roll it to a variable annuity
with him taking care of it
um no he didn't and i'm not
because this was something that was
optional um through my school district i
had gotten a settlement
and i didn't want to get taxed on it so
i was trying to figure out
where to put it this was seven years ago
but you could roll into a traditional
ira not a roth ira and not have any
taxes
and then i would be able to control the
amount of
interest in yeah and control what it's
invested in yeah
okay and do you know if you're able if
you put into a teacher
um annuity
or do you know if you're able to roll
the
roll that over um well if it was a
pre-tax
annuity if they it's up to the school
board
it's up to your particular employer i
don't know what teacher annuity can mean
a whole myriad of different things
so you'll have to find out but it sounds
like your
investment advisor didn't want fool with
us so get in touch with one of our
smartvestor pros
and ask them to to tell you in your area
in the city of um uh you know sacramento
what can you do uh and if you are able
to roll this
and just because it's in an annuity if
you roll it to a roth it does become
taxable that piece of information was
correct
but if you roll it to a if you can roll
it to a roth and it becomes taxable then
i know you can roll it to a traditional
and there's no taxes and that's what i
would do i'd move it to a traditional
and put it in good mutual funds and get
it away from there
if you're able to but i don't i do not
know what the guidelines and regulations
are
with each individual county across the
nation and what their
deal with their teacher annuity is and
tells me something that the
the the financial advisor didn't
immediately try to
grab that into another product maybe
yeah okay um should have if they're able
to but
he told her not to do it because of
taxes he didn't tell her do it not do it
because she couldn't do it
that's fair that's what's bothering me
so um i'm thinking that
uh yeah get click smart investor pro at
ramseysolutions.com and get one of our
smart investors and ask them
and they maybe can do it for you that's
a possibility so
something to something to check on for
sure
thank you for calling kareem is with us
in toronto hi kareem how are you
i'm good how are you mr ramsey better
than i deserve sir how can we help
um so i just want your opinion on
something so i'm from toronto i just uh
i'm graduating university right now i
actually just broke my last exam a few
hours ago
congratulations man what's your degree
in
uh business good for you did you pass
this last exam
i hope so i just got one exam back that
i didn't do too hard on
[Laughter]
but uh yeah so i'm uh yeah i'm gonna i'm
moving to new york
in a few months uh for a job uh and i
wonder your opinion on if i should
potentially buy an apartment instead of
renting uh in new york it would be
somewhere in midtown around three or
four hundred thousand um
and i have a fair amount saved already
um
and my job specifically doesn't allow me
to invest in a lot of stuff
that i would normally invest in so i was
thinking of that as an alternative that
i could also live in
so i was hoping to get your opinion on
that
so you said a fair amount
what is a fair amount um i have like 50
or 60 000 saved
okay what will you be making at your new
financial job
um base would be around 100 and then
bonuses variable can be between 20 and
50
for first year so i'm guessing you're
moving into an analyst role which is why
they're not allowing you to
invest in things that you might be
actually analyzing
yeah okay hey
i i like dave you you can of course
counter in i i like folks to work at
their first job out of college for a
year or two
before they just plant their roots so
deep or get real
close to their financial ceiling there
the 400 000 apartment
yeah i'm really good with you getting
settled in
and all the other changes in your life
without also becoming a real estate
owner for year one
particularly after year one yeah you
know you start to talk about it you can
use that year to pile up even more cash
by the way
and there's a possibility by the way
that manhattan midtown real estate is
going to be cheaper in a year
yeah there's a possibility yeah because
the freaking place is a ghost town
yeah for now yeah i know i don't know
i'm not more bullish on it than most
i know but i mean people are leaving
there by droves and supply demand curve
is going to affect real estate prices
i don't know what they're going to do
but i don't think they're going to shoot
straight up
um i'm pretty sure that i don't know
whether they're going to stay flat or
turned down but
um you know you've just got the
you know the the midtown economy's just
been damaged
by the continued shutdown the prolonged
shutdown so anyway no i would not buy
the first year i agree with john
and all of those other reasons i think
you move down there get you an apartment
pile up cash
uh you've obviously got a wonderful job
congratulations
making serious bucks straight out of
school pretty freaking amazing
and um and you've done a great job
saving money so far
be debt free have your emergency fund in
place and save as big a down payment as
you can save in the next
12 to 18 months and then talk about
buying that's what i would and dave i
think
again i've got my experience and just my
students who graduated but
if if he were moving to kansas making a
hundred thousand dollars
and was going to buy a 200 000 house i
would say hey just sit for a second
you don't know where you're going to
want to live in this new town you think
you want to do here you think you want
to
um you're this is going to be your
forever job like every new college
graduate does and
it ends up shifting and changing i i
just want someone to get all that stuff
settled in
now maybe that's not a rule of thumb but
no i think it is it's uh it's a time of
high transition
yeah and so and and adding one more
thing to the bowl of transition
is is is equal to stress and
aptitude to make a mistake right um so
yeah i don't disagree i think
you know it's kind of like we talk about
a young couple getting married don't buy
a house first year
same kind of a thing you know it takes a
year of being married to know how close
your mother-in-law to buy the old joke
we use over and over and over again you
know that kind of stuff
so um that's uh
that's the thing and so uh uh
you know and that's true you're in a in
a
one of the more transitional uh phases
of your entire life
right uh another way of saying it the
least stable right
uh and so and really and real estate's a
freaking anchor few people think they
know
more about how the world works than a
new business grad
what are you saying maybe a new
psychology grad what are you talking
about
dumb too but i'm telling you a 21 year
old business grad is like i think i've
got this figured out
what i need to do is this and everyone's
saying hey just be wise slow down
ah but i got it right they may he may
have it i i'll
be guilty as charged when i graduated i
i definitely knew
everything about the economy oh only to
discover i know nothing
about the economy this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
you can join him on the dr john deloney
show as well as with me today
he's on youtube on podcasts uh it's
everywhere
and make sure you jump in and you can be
a caller on his show
you can email to set that up ask
john ramseysolutions.com or you can
leave a voicemail at 844-693-3291
when it comes to making big money or
life moves like buying a home getting
married having a baby it is likely the
last thing on your mind
to make sure that you have the right
insurance coverage i get that that's
kind of nerdy but you know what
big changes are overwhelming and what
would be even more overwhelming is to
find yourself in a situation where you
didn't have the right coverage
yeah bad if not having the time or
energies what's keeping you from getting
it done get with one of our endorsed
local providers our elp insurance agents
to help their independent agents who
will help you find the best coverage at
the best prices and they don't charge an
extra dime
they get paid when you get the best deal
and buy that's how it works all you do
is text the word
insurance to 33 789 i promise you're
going to save money
text insurance to 33789
amanda is in oklahoma city hi amanda
welcome to the ramsay show
hi hey what's up so
i am 40 about to put
a single mom about to
get my last daughter out of the my last
child out of the home
um i did it i did it i'm so happy
they made it they all made it out alive
they all made it out alive and they're
happy and they're healthy and they're
amazing and
my last is happy and healthy and amazing
and it's a blessing in itself
oh man we've had a wild ride hey man so
yeah i'm very happy so
i have my emergency fund i am debt-free
good credit score and it made a point
where i want to buy
my second home um it's been a few
couple eight decade since i bought a
home
but i would like to buy a home and
um do it wisely obviously i have enough
to
put my 20 down and finance or
i could save for the next five years and
buy cash okay what if you put your 20
down and financed it and paid it off in
five years
it's the same numbers oh okay
sure if you can save up the cash you
could pay off the debt
yeah absolutely i can yeah i don't
yeah now
i don't i don't own a home now we have
had a pretty uh
rocky road the last 10 years um scraped
and scrambled just to get where we're at
and it's really a miracle that i'm where
i'm at now it's not a miracle you're a
rock star
yeah there's nothing miracle about how
hard you've worked amanda
there's another miracle about corn
coming out of the ground when you plant
corn
exactly exactly you're a hard-working
warrior princess you're a fighter
i am i am yeah what do you do for a
living i understand that
so i just got a new job i i start on the
third
and i'm in touch with her
very good so you got a new job the last
one's moving out this is this is
the year of new beginnings it's really
the year of
amazing blessings my income is only
going to skyrocket from here
um i am beyond blessed i am just
blessed mars are upon measure wow
so powerful good for you and how old are
you 40.
yeah oh you're i got a five-year-old and
i'm older than you
you're just getting the party's just
starting now how many how many uh
kids do you have eight three and how
long have you been divorced
oh my gosh i've been doing it on my own
about 16 years
but i've been divorced for 12.
okay you're a stud wow absolutely
amazing
you're fun you got hey it's great yeah
just put your you know
you're debt-free you have your emergency
fund in place you put down as much as
you can put down if 20 is what you got
that's awesome do it
and if you put it on a 15-year fixed and
the payment's no more than a fourth of
your take-home pay
we're happy because in 15 years when you
are 55 your home will be paid for but
guess what you're probably going to pay
it off in five years
because that was your plan anyway yeah
and really not much stops you so no
no nothing's going to i'm only going to
get better and then if you allow your
kids to come visit you which you may not
want them to
they can come to you it'll be awesome
that was my other question is should i
i really don't want the bother of you
know a new roof and
a new windows or having a bias
you know get any uh
guy in here trying to fix my house i was
kind of concerned about whether i should
well but also a house my kids could sell
when i'm gone
and they would have that uh honey you're
40. you don't need to be worried about
when you're gone
you just you just get a will and they'll
deal with it you're not even halfway
done yeah exactly
i i mean i'm working on my will right
now hey amanda kind of on the forefront
of my mind
amanda for the last 16 years you've been
doing this all by yourself thinking
about every other person
in the world and what might go possibly
wrong well and then when it did you've
been duct taping and wiring
it and knitting it together so it didn't
fall apart
and now you're finally gonna do
something for yourself and you're
projecting 40
years into the future to think what
might be the right decision do something
for amanda this time
buy a house you're gonna love for five
years oh
okay i'm buying my forever house there's
no such thing yeah
nobody lives in a house so condo would
be okay condo be okay but you don't buy
it because you're worried about your
kids taking care of it after you die
no i don't why because you want it i
don't have to take care of it in five
years what do you want
what does amanda want that's that's
that's john's point yeah
you've earned that that's not selfish
it's good mental health
right this is the new phase of your life
everything's new it's a fresh start
white board's going new job kids gone
got some money going to buy a house
life's good 16 years of scratching and
clawing and getting her done
and now you put three-fourths of that
energy into amanda and
like you say you're going to blossom
you're going to your income's going to
skyrocket you're going to go zoom zoom
joy's going to skyrocket it's going to
be incredible so i've
we've got a thousand folks working 967
this week
on our team john and
uh just an encouragement to you single
moms single parents for that matter out
there
i you know you're all worried about if
you're gonna mess up your kids or
something
um because you're struggling and you're
scratching and you're clawing and you're
working three jobs and
money's tight and it's hard
it's hard i
don't i mean i've got a bunch of the
children
that grew up with you that work here
yeah
and you know what they all say my mom's
a hero
they don't go oh i had it so hard
when i was a kid my mom was a single mom
and i never saw her
and i need counseling none of them say
that
zero they were raised by a warrior
princess that's right
and they all go my mom is my hero
my mom took away every excuse i could
even remotely conjure up
to be a victim yeah there's no chance i
can be a victim because i was raised by
her right she outworked me three to one
there's no chance i feel like i'm
entitled to squat
it's like my job when i show up i have a
late night and i think
man i just i need to i'm gonna sleep in
for a second and then i think
nope because dave was at this event with
me and his butt's gonna be here at 5 15
in the morning
roofing the house or whatever he's doing
up here at the building redoing the
carpet himself and so
yeah it's like i've never you just don't
see colleagues who are raised by a
single mom say anything other than
no i have a blueprint for what hard work
scratching and clawing and
love and actually they're not damaged
goods no they're resilient strong and
powerful
yeah and they're not entitled little
snowflakes
they'll just outwork you three to one
yeah because
they just that's so they know that's
what they know you guys that are
raised by the amandas of this world you
know what i'm talking about and
uh you amanda's out there yeah they will
grow up and move on
praise god we all say that by the way
and so um
the trick is for them to stay gone and
when they move out they need to stay
gone
no boomerangs here no boomerangs so uh
we're gonna just move yourself out there
and you're just we're gonna watch you
from a little short we love you
but you're gonna sit out there at a
distance amanda you're
you're a hero man thank you for being
who you were and who you're gonna be
amen very fun stuff what a great call
good stuff well that about puts this
particular hour of the ramsey show in
the books our thanks to james childs our
producer kelly daniel our associate
producer and
phone screener i'm dave ramsey your host
and we'll be back
before you know it
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
thermzyshow.com
thanks for listening
from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsay show
where debt is dumb cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host dr john deloney
ramsay personality best-selling author
is my co-host today
open phones as we take your calls about
your life and your money
anything going on in your life dr
deloney his podcast
is extremely popular these days join him
on that
and he talks about everything in the
world in the mental health field but
certainly about
boundaries and relationships and
marriage issues
all those kinds of things and you're
welcome to join us with those today as
well triple eight eight two five
five two two five thomas in san diego
starts off this hour
hey thomas how are you i'm doing great
how are you doing
better than i deserve how can we help
you
so i actually have well i have lots of
questions but today my question is for
dr
john bring them all on thomas
so a couple months ago a friend of mine
a good friend he was working for his dad
living with his parents
and something happened it wasn't
entirely his fault
but his dad kicked him out and fired him
he was not in a good situation and
last wednesday one of his best friends
died in a car accident
and so he's 19.
he doesn't have a job right now he's
staying with his friends
and i you know i've been trying to
encourage him
you know offered him a place to stay i
am just wondering how long i should wait
to talk to him about you know
finding a job and kind of getting his
life back on track
how old are you i am 18. okay
what are you doing these days man um i'm
actually a welder i make about 50 000
a year i just got engaged so i should be
getting
married next year wow
and yeah well you're a good friend man
you're doing good
and he's lucky to have you um so here
here's my experience and thoughts on
this and i'd love to hear dave's too
the unfortunate thing about grief is um
kessler says it's like a fingerprint
everybody does it differently
and so really the the greatest gift you
can give someone who's grieving the loss
of a friend
is your presence what we often try to do
is make ourselves feel more comfortable
in that silence that
that just in that darkness and we try to
give a bunch of advice and you should be
doing this and here's how you should be
feeling
and really man people just need us to
show up as he says uh
grief demands a witness you got to have
people around you
um what i've found is that people will
invite you in when you show up
meaning they will eventually at some
point usually sooner rather than later
turn to you and say hey what
what i do now and when you get invited
into that conversation
is when i'd love you to come work for me
or i've got a spot for you
i know a buddy who's got a restaurant
you can get a part-time gig or something
running at somebody who's hurting
especially their friend just died the
other day and saying well you need to
you need to you need to
i haven't found that to be super
successful even though you know
man just laying around the house is
going to be hard grief just looks ugly
and messy and different for everybody
now if you look up and it's six months
and it's a year and he's couch-surfing
and he's losing weight or gaining weight
and
that's when your a group of friends will
get together and say hey we're worried
about you
um we're really struggling to to know
how to love you what do you need from us
but right now fresh off the back of
something i would show up and
um be a presence with him what do you
think dave all right
yeah we call that um the ministry
of presence and uh the last thing
you do is you quote some pithy saying
ugh
uh or some bible verse i want you to
just go sit
and don't say a freaking word bring
tacos yeah bring donuts
yeah chocolate covered and uh they're
good for grief
and um and they're good for you sitting
there quiet too because you got
something in your mind just keep shoving
them in man
keep your mouth shut yeah and um then
uh if he asks a question i would just
turn it back on him i wouldn't answer
his question
what do you think i ought to do what do
you think you ought to do yeah
you think i ought to get a job you think
you ought to get a job
just turn it back on him because he
already knows the answer
so this kid's got this young man has
more than just grief from the loss of
his friend
he's also really pissed off at his dad
right
yeah and hurt about all of that so he's
got like
stuff upon stuff right now so again just
hanging out and bring tacos and bring
donuts and that kind of stuff i
completely agree with john
um now here's the necessity thing too
he also doesn't have the luxury
of doing nothing right financially
for a long period of time
and sometimes the faster you engage in
some activities
not to mask over your grief but to get
over yourself
and realize this whole thing may not be
all about you
uh the faster you get on with it is uh
and go get a job it gives you something
to do
and keeps your mind busy a little bit
and that's not to
not go through the proper grieving
process but uh
i mean what if he'd had a job and his
friend died well he can't quit his job
and sit and cry
he's going to keep working and still go
through the grieving process so
by the way he could go get a job and
really it would help him right now
because he gave him one less thing to
worry about
because he's also sitting around worried
about where he's going to live and how
he's going to eat
because his dad booted him out and um
self-preservation is starting to enter
into this like when we went broke john
lost everything
they were like um you know uh you know
what you do after bankruptcy someone
wouldn't work you got to
i don't have a choice i get two little
babies i got to get the dadgum lights on
you know i got a
i got i didn't have a choice i didn't
have time to sit around thinking about
what was going on i just had to
i had to make some money right and
there's something about those little
wins that are so critical
well you start you build your confidence
you build uh you can begin to work
through
the um a it's not all about you and b
um you know you didn't cause it all or
what i mean you begin to you can
you you can you you still can process
the
psychology of it uh in action while
you're in act while you're
in movement yeah yeah but there's those
moments when you just your feet feel
like they've been
encased in concrete yep and you yeah
and what you need more than anything is
i love it no
nothing that could be knitted on a
pillow yes i just need you to sit with
me
i can give you three scriptures to never
use just sit with me and never use them
yeah
ever ever ever in that situation no you
know i can just don't don't
these are not there everybody wants to
quote that it's going to be okay because
they want you to be okay
they mean well but it's just looking for
silver linings isn't the point they
emerge over time
yeah after please don't tell me how this
is all gonna work out yeah no no no i
need you just to sit and hurt with me
thomas he is um really fortunate to have
you in his life
i'll tell you that right now um he's
he's he's
blessed to have you just sit and show up
and be awkward so john
entering into this give me 15 seconds on
this
one of the antidotes for depression is
activity you're right
[Music]
the purposeful activity yeah so to not
fall into
depression as a result of all these
things happening to this guy yeah some
activity is not bad
sometimes it's as simple as getting up
and brushing your teeth and going back
to bed sometimes it's and it's it's you
work towards it
but yeah finding people going to work
sometimes
that's exactly what activity is better
than inactivity
almost 99 almost 100 of time here we go
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
thanks for being with us open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five dr john deloney is my
co-host today
anna is with us in houston hi anna how
are you i'm good how are you doing dave
better than i deserve what's up
so um i found you about oh gosh maybe a
month ago
um i've got a bit of a good question i
guess
um i lost my husband uh about four
months ago
oh i'm so sorry thank you
um you know just dealing with everything
um he he had a 401k
um account with his work that's when i
get converted to an ira
um i have some savings in you know my
own 401k
um i've gone through your baby steps and
i'm um
going to be dead you know putting money
away for retirement all that good stuff
um the only thing after that is the
house at this point
so i don't know if it makes sense to
keep them you know the ira and for my
401k as is and let it do what it needs
to do
excuse me and just start paying down my
debt out of
our my house i guess out of my you know
just my regular paychecks or
cash some of it out but that you know
that there's taxes and what not deal
on that money um to do that or is it
just you know for instance just pay down
the house
as i go along
how old are you 41.
what 41 41 oh okay i thought you said
21. so what happened what happened to
him
oh i'm sorry long fight
uh about two years yeah yeah he thought
that he fought it you know
to the end yeah i'm sorry
um how long were y'all married
uh sixteen years before actually
and how much debt do you have not
counting your house
nothing nothing everything oh it's just
the house
just the house and how much is in the
401 case in retirement and all that
um his uh if his 150
mine is 100. okay what do you make
about 140. good for you what do you do
i'm in finance actually um what do you
what do you
want what do you owe on your home uh
300.
okay all right so his 150 rolled to an
inherited ira correct
correct yes okay so it can come out
without any penalties but with taxes
at any time right that's what they told
me yeah at any time
and you're also required to remove it
systematically over the next so many
years
uh they have a required minimum
distribution on it and they just
changed it i can't think what it is off
the top of my head but
um it's like five years or something
you're gonna be pulling it anyway
oh i didn't know that okay we just
changed it about 18 months ago
and uh used to be like over 30 years but
now it's over
maybe maybe 10 years but it's a shorter
period of time anyway
and um okay we got children
i have a son yes what age
13 okay all right
and you have other savings other than
these two accounts
um i have an emergency fund um
set aside in like a savings account um
and just you know cash like you know in
and out whatever's in the bank
um well i can tell you this sharon and
i've been married almost 40 years um
our estate plan is predicated on me
dying first because she has planned it
that way
but but uh in case that doesn't happen
i'll tell you how i'm gonna react
uh i'm gonna be useless for a while if
she were to pass away before me
and um 16 years is not that much
different
it's just um you have some days that are
that that are okay and other days you
still can't breathe right
yeah exactly exactly right yeah and so i
try not to make big
financial decisions until i get at least
six months of that behind me
to where i can breathe better and the
fog on my brain lifts a little bit
the good news is there's nothing rushing
this decision
and so you could you can take that ir
that inherited ira without penalties
and do it two years from now two months
from now two days from now if you want
and put it on this house you don't have
to decide today and since you don't have
to decide the day
i'm going to recommend you try not to
decide today
okay and just give yourself some room to
cry john
yeah there's going to be this pressure
to wrap a bow
around all of this and anna that's not
how this grief is going to play out for
you
okay you're going to want to come back
you're going to want yeah you want to
come back to the spreadsheets and to i
need to do this i need to do this i need
to do this
and there's a difference between a need
to and
i have to and right now you don't have
to deal with this and i'm with dave
six to six months to a year if what you
don't have to do don't touch it right
now
yeah and then you know at that point you
may be there maybe something else
opening up in front of you and you may
go
uh i want to reach over and try to get
this house paid off that's my next big
financial goal which is not a bad goal
at all
that and the kids college are your only
two goals left that are
substantial goals and i want you to hit
both of them and you're gonna hit both
of them you make really good money
you're gonna be just fine
there's nothing there's no question
about your
survivability here i mean in terms of
financial you've got plenty
of money you make good money you've got
some money and
you don't have any debt and so you're
just you're in a really really good
place in
in regard to that there was no life
insurance
no no no life insurance is that right
correct okay all right okay so i'm just
making sure i wasn't missing something
here but
but i think still yeah let's just write
it a little while
and uh okay just you know put it in your
calendar that in january you're gonna
begin to think about it and pray about
it again in the meantime you're just
going to live and cry
and and remember when you were pregnant
with your
little one how much nonsensical
unhelpful but good intended advice you
got
from everybody at the grocery store and
it didn't matter right
somebody saw somebody pregnant and they
had some advice for you um
it's been similar hasn't it about you
need to be doing this
have you thought about this right there
is not a right way to do this
except your way through this okay and
love that
that baby of yours and um
you are strong and brilliant and
powerful y'all been fighting for two
years
this raging river will turn into a creek
at some point and it's not going to be
tomorrow and so there's not a right way
to do it
get some people around you and walk
every day make those decisions later
okay i'll just say your son once again
13 13. perfect yeah
okay so what i want you guys to do i'm
going to give you ramsey plus
for a year oh thank you and i want
it's uh where you can learn how to
handle money you probably already know
how
but we'll you can go through financial
peace university you can get on the
every dollar
and you can train him let him go through
it with you this is going to be a new
adventure that you all can do together
and you can both learn how to handle
money you can train him and you can
you can get polished up if you already
know how and
um you know as christians we're supposed
to take care of widows
and i am yeah so we're going to take
care of you today and you hang on kelly
will pick up we'll put you into ramsey
plus that gives you
financial peace university legacy
journey smart money smart kids it gives
you all the classes
uh it also gives you every dollar gives
you community it gives you access to
coaches and get questions answered
but don't do that out of feeling of
pressure to this is just kind of part of
you getting some more tools in your belt
while you're spending this year
healing and as as we talked about with
the last call um no pun intended but
it's a little baby step in a new
direction of a thing right and it's
something you can do together
and it's just uh hey let's watch a video
tonight let's do some of the assignments
let's
let's begin to slowly take these crooked
steps
in a new direction towards a new
adventure and suddenly you'll look up
nine weeks
two three months later and you've got a
little bit taller
you've got a new relationship adventure
that you've just joined in with your son
it's a whole new direction here yeah 13
year old can definitely graduate from
this class oh yeah
and he'll remember doing it with mom
yeah during a really
in the shadows in the year from hell
that's right yeah but it set me up to be
a man that's right
and um mom helped guide me through that
so that's cool
yeah that's good stuff hey he's danny
you call us anytime we can help we're
here
anytime you got a question babe we're
here and uh we we got your back
and we'll help you any way we can so
hang on kelly i'll pick up we'll get you
guys signed up for that
the little boy's lucky to have you anna
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
still on baby step number one how did
you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org budget
don't worry it's worth it
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage
sarah and adam are with us hey guys how
are you doing
welcome welcome where do you guys live
chattanooga oh just down the road not a
bad run to nashville
well good to have you up here to do a
debt free scream how much have you paid
off we paid off 70
000 in 17 months good for you
and uh what was your range of income
during that 17 months
um we started at 120 and ended at 1 30.
good for you guys
what do y'all do for a living i'm an
assistant project manager at a general
contractor and
she's an audit cpa at a firm oh very
cool
good good so what kind of debt was this
70 000
all student loans all mine all student
loans all mine
he owned it he owned it all the way she
gave him a quick glance with their eyes
when you asked that question
a little bit of an elbow went across
there but not much yeah that's good all
right good
very good how long have you guys been
married uh two years last week actually
okay
so first order business we get married
you marry the girl in the audit
department she says we're getting out of
debt i'm guessing
pretty much yeah we had to uh cash flow
a car for him and then we had to cash
flow my last semester grad school but
then we
got on it okay so lean in and knock it
out
yes and you did it fast that's pretty
impressive i mean y'all are dialed it in
didn't you
we did okay so tell me the story how'd
all this happen i was guessing but i
wasn't far off huh
uh so basically she had gone on i think
his pinterest and found a
debt chain yeah and uh we tracked it
thousand dollar increments and that was
a good visual aspect of it and
we just basically kept living since we
just graduated college we kept living
like we were in college and just
every extra dime we put towards a debt
very cool good
good and how did you all connect to us
um so i actually had a friend that got
your total money makeover book for
high school graduation and she didn't
read it i don't think
but she let me take it to the beach on
vacation so i read it
and i lived on a budget in college and
paid cash for mine
anyway so i was following the plan and
then we were dating and then i figured
out how much student loan debt he had so
we knew we were going to tackle it when
we got married so
just kind of so how long had you been
dating
before you decided before you disclosed
this adam then we broke up
then we got back together uh it was only
a couple months before she knew about it
so
okay all right and so what was it like
when she told you
we're doing this but we're doing it the
analyst way
i was kind of scared to you know ask her
to help me almost i was i offered i was
like we can wait till
you know i haven't paid off but that
would have been several years down the
road she was like no we're gonna do it
as a team
and do it together i didn't want to wait
that long
y'all are fun this is great because a
lot it's good to have these discussions
with you because you're the other side
of it and have won now
but there's couples out there listening
that are dating and like he doesn't want
to tell her he's got 70 000
in debt because
and she feels like they're drowning and
he's like looking at another truck to
trade up in
and she doesn't know how to have this
conversation so i'm
how did you do it like put take all the
audience back to that moment when you
looked across whatever table and you
said
this is what we're going to do i got 70
000 in debt
i don't know i just i it was all
like it was we weren't going to get
married like if he wasn't willing to do
it
that's what i'm doing we would have
waited like if he wasn't on the same
page
that could have possibly been a deal
breaker yeah financial peace university
was actually
one of the things that we did in
pre-medical council oh you did okay
that was really the big step and
whenever we decided we were gonna lock
down and really do it
brother you married so well man
wow this is so good you guys that's what
a great way to do pre-marriage
counseling too
i'm sure you learned a lot both of you
oh yeah and about working together and
you know pushing the whole thing through
almost as much as being on a beach
vacation and looking over
at a bar seeing your face on the cover
of a borrowed book the [ __ ] reading
she's like oh man don't you really
you're supposed to be on vacation here
yeah
but i mean like yeah wow very cool you
guys
so now that you've done it
congratulations
you're incredible proud of you what was
what advice do you have to somebody's
facing that they're brand new married
they got a pile of debt
what's the key to getting out of debt
what did you all do that you think made
the big difference
uh just keep that gazelle intensity um
you know you might have to sacrifice
knocking out to eat with your friends
just cooking at home you know
rice chicken and hot sauce you know
cheap meals and i don't sound bad
what are the beans in rice exactly yeah
um i would say
a lot of people have asked we did share
when we became debt free
on social media and a lot of people
message me and they want there to be the
secret
and there's really no secret it's
sacrificing and discipline
and then obviously the budget and then
being on the same page with your spouse
if you're married
it's just you have to be there yeah
definitely the communication aspect of
it you know once a week two or three
times a month
just talking about it laying out the
land like how are you going to do it for
the next few weeks
taking those links off that chain yeah
one at a time here we go
that's so fun very cool so how would you
rate your marriage compared to your
buddies right now
you have no debt you've worked together
on a long-term project y'all both smiled
so
tell me about it i mean there's we have
friends that have great marriages and
then
obviously they're friends that we can
see it's a little rocky but we think
we're
up there with the strongest of them yeah
i think this has really strengthened our
communication not just about money but
everything i feel like we really
communicate really well
yeah how old are you guys i'm 25. i'm
24.
all right wow man making 130 and no debt
in
the freaking world they're going to be
so rich oh my goodness
it's going to be amazing i mean we're
talking tens of millions here they don't
even
understand what the compound interest is
going to do that's okay
you can see it on his face though he's
slowly figuring it out yeah
he knew he met he married well when he
met her and he's like she's gonna
hey guys she's gonna actually go out
with me and then
when he told his buddies that she was
gonna marry him and now he's realizing
oh we're going to have lots of commas
and zeros too
man well played dude well done so uh
who are your biggest cheerleaders uh
family and friends uh
my in-laws are here today all right yeah
they're here and we have
pretty much all of our friends were
supportive we have some that like to
make fun of us but
well that's good mostly they're
supportive if your broke friends are
making fun of your financial plan you're
right on track
i've said that to you before that's it
that's it that's a classic right there
well that's cool mom and dad came up to
support you that means they were
supporting and cheering you on all the
way through and they're proud of you
we're proud of you congratulations thank
you very very well done
we've got a copy of the legacy journey
which is the next step for you guys as
you move into
completely changing your future family
tree and that'll make mom and dad real
happy
and uh and i'm gonna give you an extra
copy of total money makeover since you
borrowed one at the beach
okay and i want you to pay it forward
figure out somebody to uh loan it to on
their beach vacation or give it to you
okay and uh let's see if we can change
another life or two so well done you
guys
very well done sarah and adam from
chattanooga seventy thousand dollars
paid off in
17 months been married 24. did it 120
130 000
worth of income count it down let's hear
a debt free scream
three two
[Music]
[Applause]
i love it there's a handbook there for a
bunch of singles that are thinking about
who to marry
there was a whole bunch in that call oh
man
they're going to have a whole new
marriage now where they can go out to
dinner together
they can go to a movie chicken rice and
hot sauce yeah
i know they're going to get an entree
now it's going to be incredible that may
be a dessert
and i don't know what was more amazing
their journey or the fact that you're on
pinterest i didn't know that
well i i i probably have somebody that
works here no
i'm going with you i think dave ramsey's
on pinterest yeah i i spent a lot of
time every night
actually i actually printed off
personally those little chains
um i was a little known secret of my
other side there
john you're so full of crap i love it
you know i'm not i can't even spell pen
yes you can you're on it you're on it
sarah now it's a secret incredible just
incredible yeah the dave
the secret dave is out but hey i do i
want to go back
sarah said this meant something to me
this
wedding wasn't going to happen yeah if
he wasn't going to be a person and he
said i'll i'll pay it all off before we
get married
yeah they both they both were like they
were addressing the issue
people don't address the issues when it
messes up their marriage and then they
did it together they accelerated it boom
touchdown
what a cool couple they're heroes man
you guys are heroes well done
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
if you are feeling stuck or disengaged
in your current job if you dread getting
out of bed to go to work if you're
searching for a new job for any reason
our get hired live stream event
live tomorrow night that's why they call
it a live stream tuesday september 27th
tomorrow night
mr ken coleman will be teaching you and
uh
ramsey personality best-selling author
number one best-selling author at this
one-night event you'll learn how to get
clear
on what you do best how to get qualified
for the job you want and then how to get
connected and actually get the job
it's time to take the next step toward
doing the work you love no matter your
situation there is hope
tomorrow tuesday april 27th
take control of your career start
working toward what you were born to do
the get hired event the hired event
text hired to 33 789 it's only 20
dollars
you can watch this stream it's going to
be worth it this guy ken is an
incredible communicator incredible
teacher
uh text the word hired 233789 kristen
is in charleston south carolina hi
kristin what's up
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
hey um so i just sold my house today i
made um
21 000 profit from it and um
this is the most money i've ever had my
whole life
and i want to put it directly into my
savings account
but i just wanted advice on how i can
continue to be in a good financial
position and not be tempted to spend any
of it
congratulations how old are you thank
you
i'm 25. how long have you owned this
house
since 2017. all right you did good i can
hear her joy through the phone yeah it's
exciting
for you a nice twenty one thousand
dollar check send me twenty one thousand
i'll get joyful like
all day long yeah that's good so uh
where are you gonna live
well right now um i'm renting an
apartment with the roommate
but i plan what the lease has done to
buy my own house again once the what is
done
once the lease is over with with the
apartment
starting next year i plan on buying my
own house again
okay so you weren't living in this house
oh yes i was living in the house how
come you sold it
um i i unfortunately i separated from my
fiance
um so the money was split in half
and um balancing with a roommate um
and until this lease is done um
i would like to buy my own house that's
perfect
i love it okay and so um well here's
what you do you you uh
you can just keep it in a bank account
that's all you need to do nothing fancy
uh ask for your ask your local banker or
your credit union to open you a money
market account
do not connect it to
overdraft protection on your checking
account
do not connect it to your atm
card do not have access to it
unless you go to the branch and pull
money out
that will keep you from accidentally
impulsing when you see a
couch on sale on the weekend right
and you build some protections and make
it a little bit hard to get
it get to it does that make sense yes
sir that makes perfect sense
yeah do you understand if it's connected
to your checking account you're going to
have a tendency to i want to buy
something and i'll just keep writing
checks right
right and if you're atm the same way so
just
protect you from you which is what
you're concerned about but the good news
is you're already aware of that so
you're very unlikely to make this
mistake
how long how long have you been
separated
um about two months okay so
i would set up with your roommate is
this a friend of yours
yes yes it is okay come up with some
number
because this grief is going to wave over
you like being out
at the beach okay and it will wave over
in different seasons and at weird
moments you're going to be walking in
from somewhere
after having a great time and it's just
you're gonna feel like someone just
dropped one of those heavy blankets over
you okay
i want you to have some sort of
agreement with your roommate that you
will check in before you make a purchase
over x dollars
is that cool and that would be your
accountability partner through this
grieving process because i don't want
you to use you
you're going to have 21 000 singing
account
and like dave said it's going to be so
tempting just to
to go get that dopamine hit and feel
better go to the bank and you're just
going to have to get a new car or have
to get a new
designer oodle dog or some kind of
something go on some vacate whatever it
is
have have an accountability partner that
you got to check in with
okay i'll give you the number anything
over 300
you have to check in how's your relation
how's your relationship with your mom
and dad
oh that's pretty decent okay you might
also have that
agreement with them then okay
and that's not you not being an adult
that's just somebody that loves you
that's kin to you right that you can
check in with that's not that you have
to ask your mommy
that's not my point but my point is the
same thing john's doing is giving you
accountability
and so um one last thing i don't get to
do this very often would you mind
helping me with something
yeah sure would you talk to the audience
out there because i catch a lot of grief
when i tell people not to buy a house
with people they're not married to
because crap like happened to you
happens would you talk to people out
there that are thinking about making the
same mistake you did when you bought
this house with this goob
well um my advice would just be um
make sure this is the person you know
you want to spend the rest of your life
with
and make sure my advice is to get
married
that would be my advice yeah because you
thought you were going to spend the rest
of your life
right i was 21 when i built this house
and um i i wish i would have
you know i i think it would have been a
lot easier if i was married
um and
that would be my advice yeah don't do
don't buy a house with people you're not
married
to that's what i tell people all the
time and people sometimes that are your
age make fun of me because i'm an old
grandpa
uh but that's but it's also i have met
with
over the 30 years of doing coaching i've
met with thousands of people in your
situation and
not you know the good news is the house
sold and you're able to
make money you made money and you're
able to split the money and you're able
to get away from this problem
and get out of what a lawyer would call
a partnership
yeah a general partnership with no
partnership documentation
and so it turned out okay in the end you
made it out with your skin intact and
made a little money
but uh to go with the heartbreak you
have to go with this disposition of
assets
as if there's a divorce and yet there is
no legal track to run the thing on
the last thing you want to do when
you're grieving is math right yep
that's the that's the last thing you
want to do man yeah it's exactly right
whether you don't have
life insurance you don't have any number
of things man yeah
thank you kristen thank you kirsten
kirsten i'm sorry for for
sharing that but it's this is the reason
it it doesn't
always turn out like you think it's
going to so get things in the right
order don't buy a house until you're
married
with someone you are not married to um
and so again she got blessed and got out
of it without a problem and i'm happy
she did i didn't i didn't want her to be
punished
or something like that but i am uh she
said
you know 21 years old yeah
and um and like we talked about earlier
in a previous segment
you got it all figured out when you're
21 right and you're 41 and when you're
51
and when you're 61. i have and i i if i
have
on a much smaller scale i know you have
man talking to folks in that same
situation who are trying to split debt
oh it's harsh it's it's a it's mayhem
yeah
you couldn't you couldn't have that
conversation beforehand which led to
this
you know breakup trying to figure out
who's going to take what debt and how
you're going to split well you bought
this on that credit card and you bought
that and
the house we have to write a check for
it remember that time you use the
mustard
dude it gets contentious and messy yeah
it's it's it's like a it's like breaking
up with your roommate oh because you are
yeah yeah it's just uh yeah it's a real
problem
and we're seeing it at a a pandemic
level
but yeah too soon man it's an epidemic
anyway it may not be a pandemic but it's
definitely an epidemic
so well kirsten i'm glad you got out uh
and you got some money i appreciate the
smile on your face for the twenty one
thousand that's awesome what a win
and you needed a win i'm glad you got
the win and uh
we want you to have a a wonderful
purchase of a home when that uh money's
all still sitting there
and you've added something to it still
in the account and it's still in the
account you've added some to it
and uh your lease runs out and you're
able to do that so most excellent
very cool thank you for joining us kiddo
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books our thanks to dr john
deloney my co-host this hour
james charles our producer kelly daniel
our associate producer and phone
screener
i am dave ramsey your host we'll be back
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker
just tell alexa google assistant or siri
to play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host
dr john deloney ramsey personality and
best-selling author is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two
you jump in and we'll talk david is with
us in shreveport to start off this hour
hi david how are you
i'm fantastic how are you sir better
than i deserve what's up
i am a 1099 contractor and have been for
close to five years
and i've been trying to uh increase my
opportunities
in the same company and i applied for a
position that's still a 1099
uh and then they sent me back a a
disclosure a non-disclosure agreement
as well as a statement in there that
says that uh
should anything ever go on i would not
be able to speak
in any way negative about the company or
anyone in the company forever
not just like in a nondisclosure or a
non-compete clause or anything like that
but forever
and so i i kind of got some red flags on
that one
um and i'm trying to figure out if this
is something that i should even
try and consider to pursue or if this is
something that just sounds
way too out there or too much to be
asking if somebody to not
be able to talk freely about something
that would happen years down the road
[Music]
that's a fascinating question yeah
um well i i
uh i don't know why you would
want the freedom to bash somebody
i was just thinking yeah i mean
you know um if and especially you've
been there five years and you haven't
seen anything that needs bashing
because you're signing up for another
you're signing up for a longer trip
right
yes sir so you don't have any indication
that this is a bunch of crazy people or
something
and so um you know if a legal matter
ever came up those are excluded out of
these things
not a legal matter criminal right it's a
legal matter would be it would not be
excluded but a criminal
if someone uh is involved in uh
uh you know i don't know some kind of uh
i'm trying to think i don't drug use or
stealing money or something
or extortion yeah you that's um
you know criminal is separate from civil
and nda cannot cover criminal
john's right um so i i don't know
if i'm just trying to put my feet in
your moccasins and walking through it
for a minute
here's the thing i don't um i've got
uh i i don't reserve the right
i don't um
have a tendency to trash people that
i've worked with
um i guess i have to i've trashed a few
not not
employers but um vendors that misbehaved
i've done that um you know for instance
i think marriott sucks
as an example so um you know
and uh so i you know what do you what
are you
there's something like i was planning
that i just didn't know what to do with
it i didn't yeah
yeah it's not that you're planning it
but i'm trying to think of what
situation you would be in where you
here's the thing in our i'll tell you
what's running through my mind and i'm a
little bit of the
victim of this to say the least um
and that is is that uh everybody in our
culture today seems to think they're an
activist
and it's like your job to straighten
everybody else's life out
on social media and that's what they're
trying to prevent
and like you know your job is to
uh publicly reprimand your employer
um which if you do that here i'll fire
your butt
because if you're gonna pee in the
cereal i mean right because it tastes
bad
i'm going to fire you okay i pay you
money to feed your family
and if you're going to run me down you
know in on social media or your wife is
i'm going to fire your little stupid
activist butt
and you deserve to be fired and so
that's what's running through my mind
honestly and i'm trying to think of um
and you should be fired i mean you're
disloyal you're a horrible employee
you know and uh when you tear down the
very place that's giving you money
that's ridiculous and so you you're not
the kind of guy's going to do that but
this these are the kinds of things that
are probably running through their mind
they run through my mind too
uh because i've i've had to do that um
and i'll i'll look to future you david
and tell you in the past when i have
talked negatively about a former
employer
the only negativity that gets spread
around is on me
yeah yeah it looks it looks foolish and
stupid
yeah um and small and so man
if if you really have a really ugly
negative experience ten year
and ten years from now someone asks you
you can say yeah i used to work there i
don't like to talk about it
people will get the message right and
you don't have to go into gory details
and all that nonsense
um it just makes you look small yeah
that's true
that's true i don't think i don't think
you're losing anything unless your
intention is to be some kind of an
activist which i wouldn't support you in
doing that
so no you know not my intention i didn't
i didn't hear that i didn't i didn't i
mean your spirit's pretty clear in your
voice i hear it clearly
so yeah yeah i i don't see a problem
with it
i i um you know i'm trying to think of
times that someone has presented an nda
to me
um i signed an nda when a good friend of
mine
brought me the idea for the total money
makeover
and he wanted before he disclosed the
idea of that book to me
he wanted to me and i said dude i don't
i'm not going to steal it
and i you know if that is good we're
going to do it so that's fine i signed
it i didn't think anything about it
and obviously it's turned out i've sold
eight nine million copies of that book
so it turned out to be a good nda
a good idea and i protected him on the
idea he made a lot of money we made a
lot of money everybody's
been a lot got a lot of help so that's
when i did sign one
um and i've signed him when i've left
you signed one when you came to work
here but i was
a a high level leader and yeah there's
trade secrets blind closed doors there's
attitudes blind
yeah all kinds of just private stuff
proprietary information
yeah and that kind of stuff but i'm
trying to think when i have
oh i'll tell you when i've been
unwilling to sign an nda is if somebody
that
just calls and asks for a meeting here
and they have and i've never heard of
them and i don't know them
and they've got this idea that they want
to bring us and i just go uh you know i
don't really want to know about your
idea because
ideas are done a dozen people who can
pull them off for zero
and so uh there's not many and so i
don't i don't really want to
get into cause we've got people all over
this building with ideas and we may have
already had the idea that you're
bringing in here so
i don't want to convolute the waters
with that so that's a time that i've not
done it
um because i there i get the people
pouring ideas across our desks every day
around here inside the building we don't
have to do that and we don't we're not
known for stealing ideas in the
marketplace so
um you know that's the other thing so i
yeah
i would sign it i would sign it unless
you've got something
in that company that you think there's
something bad going on
and they're just trying to trap you in a
sense
but you've been there five years you
wouldn't be ready to continue the
relationship if you thought that
so that's an interesting question it
gives me pausing makes me want to stop
and think
yeah yeah so and if you see something
that you don't like
that's when you've got to be the
grown-up and say i'm out yeah or i'm
going to stay
tap out and you all have a choice i
don't you know i had a
company i was working for when i was in
my 20s and they said this is the way
it's going to be and i said oh no it's
not and they said yes it is and i said
no it's not going to work
have a great work here anymore yeah have
a great afternoon it's america it's not
russia
yeah you know and i don't have to be
here anymore and so
johnny paycheck moment you know
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
if you're feeling tired or stuck with
your money like you're never going to
get out of debt
or you'll never save enough for your
future it doesn't have to be that way we
can show you how to win with this
you can make progress with your money
and you can make it faster than you
think
but the only way to make it happen is
with a budget
and that's why you need a ramsey plus
membership you'll get access to the
premium version of every dollar
the world's best budgeting app where you
can plan out every
dollar that you're going to spend and
save before the month begins
you can connect your budget to your bank
so you never miss a transaction you can
get custom budget reports
and of course when you're a member of
ramsey plus you can go through financial
peace university get help from a coach
and everything else
if you want a free trial to ramsey plus
you can start winning with money i
promise
all you got to do is text trial to 33
789 you get a free trial to all that
stuff
text trial two three three
seven eight nine
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible deal
today's question comes from alexis in
florida alexis writes
my mother and grandmother were recently
in a car accident in which my
grandmother
was killed grieving the loss of a loved
one is hard enough but this is worse
because my mom was driving
mom's always been very anxious and now
she blames herself for this
what can i say or do for her at this
time
ugh i'm so sorry alexis wow um
honestly you can tell her that you love
her and you can
show up there is no
like we talked about in an earlier show
there is no um
things you can knit on a pillow there's
no books you can hand someone that's
going to make this okay
grieving's hard and grieving's
individual and everybody does it
differently and this is just
going to be hard you can show up and be
with
you can if you're not in the same
community you can set up a
you know a dinner train and you can
call your mom every day but this is just
going to be really hard
really really hard
yeah there's not a um there's just not a
formula no
everybody grieves differently well and
it just it takes some time
and um you know we talked about this
like you said in another hour
um when i was a young guy i was doing uh
i first met god i was in a church and
they were teaching us to do
uh how to work in the altar and a
pastoral care position
as a lay person and um they always
talked about the ministry of
presence that's right don't say pithy
things say nothing like in this case the
one that comes to mind is don't say
well that's why they call them accidents
because it's an accident
it was an accident and that is why they
call them accidents and she's not at
fault
and saying that is not helpful at all
but that's what comes to mind
immediately that popped into my head
when i saw this
so um i was at a as
with a small group of writers and poets
once and a guy stood up and we were
talking about grief
and art and he stood up and told maybe
that
the most incredible heart-aching story
i've ever heard in my life
ever and uh it involves his son being
hurt and something that was
that it was an accident but he was he
was at the helm and
he told the story of he didn't remember
much other than carrying his son
and he handed him to a nurse and then
they got onto a helicopter and then
he said i remember this nurse walking me
down a hall in this
hospital turned out and took me to a
chapel didn't even know where it was
hour one hour two he said he said
nothing this nurse
somebody came in and whispered into his
ear at hour four or five he
found out later that he was being
clocked out the nurse just sat there
he said at some point the nurse got up
we hugged he left and i walked back in
when they said hey your son's out of
surgery
son made it and he said that man sat
with me for four or five hours and said
zero words
and that was the first time i'd ever
felt and seen jesus
said nothing just sat with me in a
chapel
in a hospital and there's something
about grief that demands to be witnessed
you gotta just overcome that urge to
give advice and to say well you know you
should be feeling this and what if you
just did this
and just say mom i'm so sorry you're
hurting and i love you and i'm here
i'm so sorry and that you're hurting i
mean i brought down mr grandma too
yeah i miss grandma too yeah and um i
love you
and at some point you can say hey mom
let's go for a ride i'm gonna drive
and that's mom's um introduction back
into a car
right and back into the road and over
time she'll be back on the road
and it's just going to be hard and it
doesn't matter if she was very anxious
or not
everybody's going to deal with this
grief differently but this is going to
be hard and it's going to be slow and
it's going to be different
and some some mothers will pop right
back up and say what a wild thing
i'm back in it most won't and your job
is not to direct and
and curate their grief don't fix it just
be with them
don't right and that's a hard thing to
do in a society full of fixtures oh my
gosh
everyone's got advice and and and
opinions
and and a poem seven step steps to the
new
man when you're in the car and someone
you love passes away
everything is different from this point
forward and over time that will emerge
and grow
in this ash but right now we're just
going to sit in it
wow allen is up next allen's in
louisville kentucky
hey alan how can we help well
dave i've got an interesting situation
we have
been on your plan for a long time
we've probably led up to
i don't know 30 times wow so
a problem i know one of the answers to
this
hey dave i don't even know the question
and i can't wait all right go ahead alan
i know the financial answer but i'm glad
that and i called because
dr d is on because this is a
relationship thing as much as anything
else
we've been married for 38 years
we i got the best wife in the world
exactly we are no there's nothing except
we're on baby step seven
okay haven't had a home mortgage in the
fifties
so you're millionaires likely yep
you're baby step millionaires all right
last summer my 91 year old father passed
away
and i learned
i learned from some good people which is
one reason why we've been successful
together
and dad left us between my brother and i
about another million and a half so up
to this point
most all of our assets have been in
qualified plans
and real estate so it's been illiquid to
do
i don't want to run out of time so
you're going to ask your question i'm
with you
so i want to buy about a 20 000 toy
it's not a financial issue but i'm
struggling one in my heart to say it's
okay to do that
and two my wife and i can't seem to get
on the page about it what's the uh
what's your net worth
right now about 2.3 what's her what's
her objection and what's the toy
i want to get well i've always always
joked about getting a motorcycle but
i'm your age so i'm too damn old to have
one of those so i want to get
a polaris slingshot that would
you'd be a little safer you know so it's
about
unused 20 new maybe 35. what is her
objection what is her objection to you
spending this
she thinks it's unsafe or unwise it out
of her that's the problem i i
you know it's it's not a financial issue
in our world i don't think no it's not
right john yeah yeah this has to do with
either
safety this has nothing to do with the
purchase you guys can afford this six
ways to sunday so um
i if it's a money thing buy it i think
you need to sit down and look at your
wife across the table
it sounds like you may be a dreamer
you're a storyteller you love
the the heart and soul of all the stuff
sit down and say hey i really want to
get this thing
and i can hear your voice that you don't
want me to have it or you've said no
tell me what the true objection is
what's really going on yeah
it's probably about safety and no matter
what she says go no but really
yeah no but really what's the real
objective are you worried about it no
but really
what's the real objection i can tell you
what sharon said
it has nothing with my age she said if i
get a motorcycle she's gone
and i've ridden on a polaris with you
and it's almost not as safe right if
well there you go
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five jamie's in pittsburgh
hey jamie how are you hi
um i'm so excited to talk to you you too
what's up um okay so here's my situation
i'm 26 years old recently engaged
i live with my with my parents
for the past four years after graduating
college to pay off student loan debt
last year my mom left out of the blue
and wants to divorce my dad
so because i recently got engaged
i'm trying to plan a wedding and it just
doesn't feel right
with my mom not being involved i haven't
really spoken to her
also my fiance and i want to move across
the country
we aren't really sure what to do because
combined we're in a hundred and five
thousand dollars worth of
student loan and car debt
well you've got a lot of chaos going on
yeah i'm sorry there's a lot of highs
and a lot of lows all in one
explanation right and so uh what do you
what do you do for a living what's your
fiance do for a living what do you all
make
what's your incomes yes um i'm in the
architecture industry i make fifty two
thousand dollars
um my fiance is in insurance sales
um his his base pay is 38 000.
so when are you getting married
commission will be uh
we haven't set a date because i'm like
hesitant with
with debt and with family
and um when where would you move and
when would you think about moving
um we we'd like to move either to
texas possibly austin or dallas
or north carolina and probably charlotte
and new york
jobs lined up uh we don't yet
um i feel like so
who's paying for the wedding
my dad said that he would contribute ten
thousand dollars
to the wedding and my fiance and i
could um we both would like to
contribute five thousand dollars
so you have a fifteen thousand or five
thousand each
five thousand each there's so twenty
thousand dollar wedding
okay and and why haven't you reached out
to your mom
um well she she left my dad
um and i found out through somebody else
um i so why haven't you reached out to
your mom
um you're an adult architect
who's about to get married why haven't
you reached out and asked your mom what
in the world she's doing and why she did
it
um i'm scared okay that's an honest
truthful answer and i honor that
you got a lot a lot of chaos in your
life
and it sounds like what you need to do
is sit down and write this stuff down on
a piece of paper so you can look at it
it all feels super overwhelming
and it's going to get more and more
paralyzing and that's when people get
into situations that are way way over
their heads
okay i'll give you an order and then
you've got to figure out how to navigate
it
it just sounds to me like and this is
not as much financial coaching as it is
i've been through
three adult kids getting married there
were no divorces in the middle of them
um but the uh uh
i i would get married move
and then work on the student loan debt
in that order
okay and i would get married soon
we we want to get married and you're not
getting married
you're putting off getting married for
the wrong reasons
other people are controlling your
destiny and that's ridiculous
yeah you need to set the table and put
out the dinner invitations and whoever
comes comes
to the table okay and the table is mom
i'm planning a wedding june 15th uh
july 15th august 1st
and um i've got a 20 000 budget i'm
putting it together
i'd like to know what the flip is going
on inside your brain number one
number two i'd like to know if you want
to be involved in planning this wedding
if you want her involved yeah and then
you don't wait on
her to figure out her life for you to
get married
because she's going to come back with
different dates and that doesn't work
for me and what if we did it in
nope nope this is when it's happening
and if you want to be involved these are
the terms of you being involved you may
not want her involved i don't know
you may have written her off because of
something she's done and you're not
telling us what
the whole story and you know more of it
than you're letting on i think that's
what's going on but
and if that's what you want and dad
comes out and says well then i'm not
coming then dad's made his decision too
this is where grown-ups are being
grown-ups now
so don't wait on your mom and dad to get
their crap together for you to get
married
that might be never because it's gonna
be a while
okay and they're obviously pretty
screwed up
i think you should go see if you haven't
already go
sign up for premarital counseling monday
yeah
because you all have a lot of time good
good
good take that seriously do all those
exercises
set a wedding date this summer get
married
make a move and work on your student
loans with your new jobs make the move
only when you have new jobs
don't move and hope it all works out oh
we're going to texas and god will take
care of us no god says get a job before
you go
okay so we should just save up um really
as much as we can once we set the date
um because we we're started saving but
then
we're like oh what should we put this
towards you alone should we
no just put you just put your student
loans on as much hold as you can put
them on
and get through the move and get through
the wedding
the wedding and then the move and get
landed in two good jobs
settle down there you can check in on
your parents and hope they're doing well
hope they're starting to heal hope
they're putting their lives back
together meanwhile you're going to tear
in
tear into these student loans like a
vengeance
but you can't really do six things at
once that's what's driving you nuts
isn't it
yeah you can't fix your mom you can't
fix your mom you get married
pay off your student loans and move and
because your mom did something stupid
now you're questioning the whole
enterprise and are you safe are you
smart who's this lady you don't trust
yourself you don't trust your family
it all just feels too much right yeah
i have paid off fifty three thousand
dollars of student loan debt so far
since i've graduated
so that all happened before all hell
broke loose
yes yes yeah so you made good progress
i'm proud of you i'm not saying that
but right now you've got a bunch of
things on your table
and listen you can eat an elephant if
you just do it a bite at a time so all i
did is give you an order if you want to
change the order change the order i
don't care
but the problem is when there's no order
there's no one
before two before three and i'm just
saying
wedding before move before
student loans
you that's my opinion it's worth what
you paid for it kiddo and anytime you
are faced
this is for any listener anybody you're
faced with this those seasons of chaos
and we all have them
write it down get somebody in your life
that will read it back to you say are
you really going to do it like this
and you go oh no no no it's just getting
ordered to that chaos and then like the
baby steps
come up with your plan and start walking
it well you can flesh it out
you know in her situation okay we could
do it in a different order we're going
to move
and then we're going to get married yeah
that doesn't work so good nope
uh oh wait we're going to pay off all
the student loans well there's 105
000. yep it'll be a little while before
we get married before we move then we're
going to be in daddy's basement a while
right this is going to continue so i
mean when you play all these things out
there's only really one order that's
going to be the the most efficient and
logical a common thing is she wants to
make sure mom and dad are okay before
she goes and pulls her trigger and you
can't do that
oh yeah mom and dad are going to be a
mess that's probably been brewing for a
long
there's so much back to that right
you've got to charge your course at this
point and i love your wisdom
tell mom what here's the plan tell dad
here's the plan
yeah and we're moving forward we're
serving dinner at six if you want to eat
be there i'd love to have you there
yeah and if you only save up fifteen
thousand for the wedding
nobody's gonna die right yeah oh by the
way
ten ten's gonna you're gonna have a
great wedding and the pictures are gonna
look great 20 years from now
and that's what you'll remember that's
i've lots of weddings around here these
young
people on our team getting married lots
of ten thousand dollar wedding oh yeah
lots of them the marriage works just as
good yeah there's no correlation between
the cost of the wedding
and the success of the marriage and
matter of fact at some point there may
be an inverse yeah
ah this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day psalm 16 5 and
6 lord you alone are my portion and my
cup
you make my lot secure the boundary
lines have fallen for me
in pleasant places surely i have a
delightful
inheritance charles kettering said every
father should remember that one day his
son will follow his
example not his advice
nice job kettering they will watch
everything you do and do it perfectly
yep
they won't listen to you but they will
watch you you don't believe me try
opening your mouth and one of your
parents comes out
oh trust me it's happening dude
i got an 11 year old and a five-year-old
dave i i hear it and
you just have to look over your
shoulders my old man is he my dad here
what is happening
how did that just come out where'd that
come from and then i watched my son make
the same face i made i could feel it
like ah man it's like living in the
matrix it's so bizarre
rachel says more is caught than taught
that's so true you want your children to
be good with money
let me teach you how to do that you be
good with money
uh it's so much easier just to tell them
stuff dave and do it in front of them
yeah yeah don't hide it don't hide all
of your money secrets
because they're not really secrets after
all hey while we're on that topic let me
ask you this
what's what is a rule of thumb you've
experienced over the years telling kids
your salary
because i really like having especially
my 11 year old down there watching us do
the budget and watching
because i want him to have an
understanding here's how much
electricity costs and water costs and
those kind of things
but also just having innate fear of him
running around school saying hey
what does your parents make my parents
you know what i mean yeah i
uh you know i shared all the expenses
but i never shared the income
okay until they were 18 okay or until
they were in college or whatever
they knew we were doing okay you know
kind of thing but they
um uh i didn't but we were also trying
to protect our kids from the celebrity
crap as well
right you know they the um because we
were trying to make sure they don't play
the dave card at school to try to get
some kind of
favor right now or something my dad's
dave ramsey you know that kind of bull
crap and so you just got to step
on that with a big foot and so um
truthfully none of them ever did it much
except rachel yeah
i think my son lies about his last name
and no it's de la nay
i'm not that guy right well yeah
and there's some of that i mean because
there's two sides to that part that's
right i mean there's a lot of french
guys interested
try try being in a financial uh a
personal finance class in college and
your dad's name is dave ramsey yeah that
would be a pain in the butt
so that that really happened um didn't
go well
and so uh uh but yeah seriously i can
see rachel she won't back down either
no and yeah daniel would nod politely
rachel would say excuse me
yeah daniel waited till the end of the
semester and then told the guy's last
name
right right he didn't even get it the
guy didn't even understand how stupid he
was but um
the uh uh but the yeah i uh no we didn't
share
incomes and uh but it's protecting the
11 year old from himself i think but
well and
they you know because they just um
you know they uh even if something is
the truth
you don't want them bragging that's why
you don't want them
uh embarrassing
themselves or the family or whatever
else i mean it's just
you don't want them being that kid you
know like a rub you know my dad makes
sense yeah
my mama makes sense though yeah you know
you know
that's a gross kid but i like that idea
of of sharing the expenses making sure
they see this yeah they did i mean i
remember
distinctly rachel and uh
maybe denise sitting at the kitchen
table and we're going over the electric
bill
and denise goes oh my gosh
it costs so much to buy electricity
and like rachel looked at her and goes i
guess that's why they're telling us
close the door all the time
turn the lights off right it's like but
there was just no pun intended light
bulb moment that came
on right and um you know it's just but
that
that's really good i love those
conversations and you know get the
mutual fund
statement out and go here's the share
price and here's the number of shares in
your
college fund right and so how do you
figure out what your how much money is
in your college fund you multiply those
times each other i
love that and it's a little little sixth
grade math lesson fourth grade
math lesson there whatever it is to get
to that point and work that through but
it's value building
and uh and then you have to you know you
have to constantly correct
uh for them we just we squashed out
any type of entitlement oh yes stuff
like rachel and i told the story in the
uh smart money smart kids series in the
book and in the
teaching series she does in ramsey plus
um
daniel was a little guy you know about
seven eight years old we finally got a
decent car
after going broke and you know and you
know we had an old we're old southern
people so you get a new car
everybody piles in you go for a little
ride right that's a like a celebration
of the buying the new car you know what
i'm talking about
yes and so daniel gets he leans back in
the back seat all the way back and he
goes
we're doing pretty good yeah and i said
honey
we ain't doing anything you got nothing
you got nothing i'm doing pretty good
you you're just along for the ride buddy
and so
he's like the kids told that story for
years because like daniel's like
okay okay i just thought it was like
when i got this latest truck this this
fine 06 model
hank got in it he looked at it he looked
at me
based on the old truck i was driving
yeah it's a pretty sizeable upgrade
he said dad are we rich
yes we are so yes we are
we have a good used pickup that's right
we are rich
this truck cost five digits
not just uh yeah not not everybody has a
five digit pickup
this truck had a tin in front of the
comma
whoa dad that's right son stay close to
your old man he'll get you places
oh my gosh well the the thing is yeah
you do want to share and
on the other side the other thing we run
into with kids how much to discuss
is when things aren't going well right
you don't want to scare them right you
can terrify kids yeah you can
terrify them we're gonna get four
clothes down and thrown in not
it where available can digest it and
obviously you can disclose more to a 14
year old than you can a four-year-old at
least hypothetically
and um i've learned in those
conversations that touch
is a huge settling thing for a kid if
i'm having a hard conversation with
with a young kid i'm going to sit them
on my lap i'm going to make sure i'm
touching their face touching their hands
and it's a grounding force for a kid
they can hear it and they can see me
right
as opposed to just throwing off a piece
of information that i got more context
to and that kid's going to take that and
just run with it
right and they're like neural pathways
it's just i need them to be grounded and
know that um i got you
i got you we're here this is a hard
season this is really tough times
and dad's working to plan him with mom
and we're going to figure this out
because they
they can um that they can sense it they
can
feel the stress in the air and if you
don't call it out they will assume that
stress is
created by them and they will spend the
rest of their life trying to solve it
yeah right and they get you got to let
them know there is stress in the air it
is not you in fact you're the best part
of this
and we're going to make it we're having
grown-up challenges and
luckily you got grown up assault on them
that's gonna make it that's right we're
gonna make it that car
that car is not gonna be in the driveway
anymore we're gonna make it yeah
we sold the boat oh boy you know
we're gonna make it yeah and um but
you're gonna be okay we're gonna have
food
and we got each other and we're gonna go
kick a soccer ball out right now yeah
yeah and we'll work it out but that's um
you gotta be real careful because well
children deserve to know
not really you can weaponize truth in a
way that makes you feel tough
and makes you feel back in control don't
do that to a kid
yeah right call your buddy and tell him
you're scared to death that's why you
got to have people in your life right
yeah and you know and and but it is good
to
also the other side of it is to
acknowledge it you need to acknowledge
it
keeping it keeping completely stuffed
they know something's up
and they they think it's worse than it
is and there's some conventional
parenting wisdom
years ago was don't have disagreements
in front of your kids
you don't want to scare them and
inadvertently
i never saw my parents generation of
kids that don't know that you can fight
and still love somebody right
yeah yeah kids grow up uh parents never
talked about sex parents never talked
about money figured they hadn't either
found out later they had both
i know and i didn't want to know any of
it
don't want to know this i don't want to
know this uh
dr john deloney good show today thank
you rob james childs and kelly daniel in
the booth i am dave ramsey your host
will be back with you before you know it
in the meantime remember there is
ultimately only one way to financial
peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you